welcome back to another Christmas theme
top five I'm Walter benezia I'm Heather
Ruth and I'm Ayanna Wade since you all
made us watch horror movies for the last
Christmas top five I thought this week
we can count down some of our favorites
yes I just rewashed Bullards Oh like
whole die hard
whoa I'm sorry what I heard it not a
Christmas movie of course it is I don't
feel like it's really Christmas until I
hear at the dry ho-ho-ho of Hans Gruber
I'm tired of having this argument with
people fine let's settle this once and
for all let's see what Twitter thinks
Twitter is never wrong
diehard was released in July of 1988 it
follows the story of Officer John
McClane who travels from New York to Los
Angeles in hopes of spending the
holidays with his estranged family he
attends a party at Nakatomi tower where
his wife works the tower is seized by
terrorists led by Hans Gruber McClane is
not taken with the rest of the hostages
and he tries to fight back this movie
helps cement Bruce Willis as an action
star and launched the career of Alan
Rickman as it was his first major motion
picture even though it received fairly
mediocre reviews at the time of its
release it is now considered by some as
one of the greatest action movies or
even movies ever made many websites and
critics have also ranked it among the
best Christmas movies Walter what do you
think well I mean Bruce Willis has that
it isn't a Christmas movies this is my
episode now these are the top five
reasons why die hard is a Christmas
movie number five the time setting just
because the movie takes place on
Christmas Eve does not make it a
Christmas movie this is the most obvious
reason why some claim the movie is a
Christmas movie it takes place on
Christmas Eve at a Christmas party
now this in and of itself doesn't really
qualify it as a Christmas movie what
matters is the fact that it is Christmas
pushes forward certain plot elements
MacLean only is coming to LA in the
first place because of the holiday
Christmas is the reason for the party in
the first place
admittedly this is the weakest of our
reasons so let's move on to some more
solid ground number four
the music Christmas music is the perfect
way to get into the holiday spirit
every Christmas movie needs an
appropriate soundtrack Oh
diehard features a number of holiday
songs and themes throughout the movie
[Music]
when they are used they are used well to
set a particular tone
one of my favorite elements of this is
the integration of some Christmas themes
into the background music listen here as
the music references the ode to joy and
then transitions into a theme of lettuce
snow
[Music]
another standout feature is the jingle
bells used the movie even ends with a
rendition of let it snow it's a
wonderful homage to the holiday as well
as the banker bonds that are falling
from the tower at the end so whether
it's subtle or obvious the movie makes
an effort to include Christmas music and
themes throughout integrating the
Christmas theme even more into diehard
[Music]
number three Christmas references some
of the best lines and moments in die
hard reference Christmas
this movie is chock-full of references
to the holiday and Christmas well wishes
one of my favorite lines is only
possible because of the Christmas
setting and there's this iconic moment
twas the night before Christmas two by
two cover formation
I will admit these references are
stronger in the beginning and the end of
the movie with the middle lacking and
some Christmas references but it's still
there
spoilers here so if you still haven't
seen diehard skip ahead and for the love
of God go watch it when McClane fires
the shot that leads to the death of Hans
the gun he uses is ripped off of his
back after being held there with
Christmas tape if the setting were just
incidental the audience would not have
been reminded of the holiday throughout
the movie number two a Redemption arc
you might think this is a stretch but
hear me out on this some of our most
familiar and beloved Christmas tales
involves someone who changes for the
better because of the season or the
trials that they faced during the
holiday whether it be Scrooge or the
Grinch although John McClane's
Redemption arc may not be quite so
dramatic it's still there he starts the
story as a man stressed and separated
from the ones he loves he comes to LA in
the hopes of mending some fences and
reconnecting with his family this seems
like an almost hopeless task before the
terrorists come to the tower he and his
wife Holly that's right
Holly fight she takes their family
picture down one of the biggest points
of contention is that she begins to use
her maiden name you are a married woman
Holly you're married to me never
finished his conversation today
I had to take right no matter what the
consequence is no matter what it did to
our marriage any marriage the shared
trauma helps bring John and his wife
Holly back together and really see
what's important in life
it's family there's a wonderful moment
when John realizes that he may not make
it out alive and really shows how much
he has grown throughout the ordeal she
don't really say I'm sorry then I want
you to tell her that Alan will you tell
her that John said that he was sorry no
matter how much they may have fought
they see that they need to be reunited
to be truly happy again
[Music]
and the number one reason why diehard is
a Christmas movie is the traditions I
know so many people who have made
diehard a part of their Christmas
traditions whether it be with family
friends or loved ones people all across
America watch this movie every year
there has been a multitude of Christmas
related media based around die hard for
people to enjoy together
last year I went to a holiday musical
performance of die hard it was amazing
there's a mock children's book that
recently came out that parodies twas the
night before Christmas I would highly
recommend it for any diehard fan in your
life overall die hard is now a part of
the culture surrounding Christmas so
agree or disagree it's a tradition that
Bond's people together and isn't that
what Christmas is about coming together
with the people we love to create
memories let's let bygones be bygones
and just enjoy each other's company this
holiday season sounds good did I hear
you mention a die-hard picture book oh
yeah it's great
I've actually got it right here if you
guys want to read it sure let's just
wrap up the show and we'll start our own
new holiday tradition well we want to
hear what you guys think is diehard a
Christmas movie what traditions do you
have around die hard what do you want to
see us cover next on the show leave a
comment and let us know to keep in touch
you could like my Facebook page or
follow along on Twitter you could find
me on Facebook Twitter Instagram or
subscribe to my animated movie review
series right here on YouTube and you can
find me on Twitter Instagram or Twitter
I stream on Wednesday nights we'll catch
you right back here next week with a
brand new episode of top 5
[Music]
[Applause]
you
Oh real good baby just because the movie
I'm gonna do that again yep
Christmas music is the appropriate is
the proven why I can I say I know so
many people who have made daya sounds
great well well done twas the night
before Christmas and up in the tower
everyone was partying except one
Wallflower bearer bonds fluttered like
fresh fallen snow as Holly embraced her
blood-spattered bow so merry Christmas
to all be kind to one another and most
of all yippee-ki-yay mother
you